hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers Chris
who is worried that he's going to be
hiring salespeople because he's not
really good at sales we wanted the
higher sales people and is worried that
they're going to you know run the
business and then leave and take these
customers with him and he won't be left
with anything so how do you control your
sales people so they don't leave the
company and start their own business and
compete against you so thank you the
crushed question Chris there's two quick
things that I would answer here the
first is you need to build something so
that your sales people can't just sleep
you need to build an engine so it starts
with you so what do you bring to the
table if you're not doing sales you're
doing something else right you're
sourcing your product or service or
you're the expert or you've got to be
doing something else in your business
and you want to build an engine so that
the sales is an important process but
it's only one part of your entire
business so if a sales person left sure
it'd be great at sales but it didn't
have everything else in the company so
you know there's a there's not a strong
incentive to want to leave because he
knows that you can't do everything
himself if the sales person thinks this
is really easy i'm the only one really
running this business then maybe I
should just go leave and start my own
thing and compete so you need to build
that whole engine around it and
hopefully you you know you're adding a
lot of value to business yourself and
you bring on other people as part of
your team so that it's not just the
sales person who can you know run away
with your clients that's the first thing
the second thing is you want to make
your company a place that people want to
work right you want to be somebody
people want to work for if people like
their boss and they are really enjoying
the opportunity they're not likely to
leave unless you give them a reason to
leave so you want to give them trust you
want to show them they have
opportunities to develop and that you
know it's a fun place to work they're
going to learn a lot there's
opportunities for growth they have a
chance to do what they're excited and
passionate about and you want to be a
supportive boss as much as you can so
they don't have it a reason to want to
leave right if people come to work every
day they're really happy
doing it they're not going to want to
leave or if they're thinking about
starting their own business it's going
to be a lot harder to want to do compare
it to you they had a really bad box who
treated them like garbage and you know
they didn't you know get along with them
very well they didn't enjoy the work
environment so treat them well you know
have a good place where people want to
work and they won't have a strong
incentive to want to leave you and go
somewhere else so the first part is
build that system so it's not just a
sales person they see that leaving they
would be missing everybody else in the
business that kind of makes it run and
then to make it a good place to work
where people don't want to leave you now
it doesn't mean they're not going to
leave you you can never completely avoid
that but that will help prevent it as
much as possible and hopefully give you
employees who want to stay with you for
a very long time so hopefully that helps
Chris if you guys like the video please
give it a thumbs up below and I'd also
love to hear you have to think you can
run leave a comment under the video or
if you have something else to add to
chris's question then please leave it
below and we'll see you on the next
episode
you
you